is there
some version of the alien conversation
that could incorporate
the breaking of frameworks well i think
so i mean the key question would be
uh we've had the pentagon release
multiple videos of strange ufos that
undermined
a lot of us i just think it's also
really fascinating to talk about the
fact
that those of us who were trained to
call bs
on all of this stuff just had the rug
pulled out from under us by the pentagon
choosing to do this and you know what
the effect of that is
you've opened the door for every stupid
theory
known to man my aunt saw a ghost
okay now we're gonna have to listen to
well hey
the pentagon used to deny it then it
turned out there were ufos dude
whoever is in charge of lying to the
public
they need a cost function that
incorporates the the
damage and trust because i held this
line that this was all garbage and all
bs
now i don't know what to think there's a
fascinating aspect to this
alien discussion the breaking of
frameworks that involves the release of
videos
from the pentagon which is almost like
another dimension
that trust in itself or the nature of
truth and information
is a kind of dimension along which we're
traveling constantly
that is uh messing with my head to think
about because
i mean like because it almost feels like
you need to incorporate that
into your study of the nature of reality
it's like
the constant shifting of the
notation the tools we use to communicate
that reality
and so like what am i supposed to think
about these videos is it
is it a complete distraction is it a
kind of cosmic
joke i don't know but you know what i'm
tired of these people just completely
tired of these the
the the people the on the pentagon side
or the people who are interpreting the
stuff on the pentagon side i'm tired of
the entirety i'm tired of the
authorities
playing games with what we can know
the fact that you and i don't do you
have a security clearance
uh some level of it for because i was
funded for darpa for a while
i don't have a security clearance you
know i
i am going to release whatever theory i
have
and my guess is is that there is zero
interest from our own government
um and so the chinese will find out
about at the same time
our government does because lord knows
what they do in these buildings
i i watch crazy people walk in and out
of the intelligence community walk in
and out of darpa
and i think wow you're talking to that
person that's really fascinating to me
we don't seem to have a clue as to who
might have the ball
complete lack of transparency do you
think it's possible there's
the government is in possession of
something
deeply fundamental to understanding of
the world
that they're not releasing so this is
one one things is
this is one of the famous distractions
that people play with the narrative
assume that that were true
of alien life forms uh spacecraft and
possession
that the government is in possession of
alien spacecraft that's assuming that
the narrative yeah i don't think the
government really exists at the moment
i believe and this is not an idea that
was original to me
there was a guy named michael teitelbaum
who used to be at the sloan foundation
and at some point i
pointed at the u.s government had
completely contradictory objectives when
it came to the military in science
and one one branch said this one branch
said that i said you know i don't
understand
which is true what does the government
want he said you think there's a
government
and i said what do you mean he said what
makes you think that the people in those
two offices have ever coordinated
what is it that allows each office to
have a coherent plan with respect to
every other office
and that's when i first started to
understand that there are periods where
the government coheres
and then there are periods where the
coherence just decays and i think that
that's been going on since 1945
that there have been a few places where
there's been increased coherence but in
general everything is just getting less
and less coherent
and that what ward did was focus us on
the need to have a government of people
emission
capacity technology commitment ideology
and then as soon as that was gone um
you know different people those who had
been through world war ii had one set of
beliefs those born in the 1950s
uh you know or late 40s by the time they
got to woodstock
uh they didn't buy any of that so
coherence is the
is that the complete opposite of like
per of bureaucracy being paralyzed by
bureaucracy
so coherence is efficient functional
government because when you say there's
no government meaning there's no
uh emergent function from a collection
of individuals it's just a bunch of
individuals
stuck in their offices without any kind
of efficient communication with each
other on a single mission
and so a a government that is
truly at the epitome of what a
government is supposed to be
is when a bunch of people working
together what are we about are we about
freedom are we about growth
are we about decency and fairness uh
are we about the absence of a national
culture so that we can all
just do our own thing i've called this
thing the usa and
the united states of absolutely nothing
these are all different
visions for our country so it's possible
that there's a
alien spacecraft somewhere and there's
of like
20 people that know about it and then
they're kind of it like as you
communicate
further and further into the offices
that information dissipates it gets
distorted in some kind of way and then
it's completely lost the power the
possibility of that information is lost
we bought a house and i had this idea
that i wanted to find out what all the
switches
did and i quickly found out that
your house doesn't keep updating its
plans
as people do modifications they just do
the modifications and they don't
actually record why they were doing what
they were doing or what things lead you
so they're all sorts of bizarre
like there's a switch in my house that
says privacy
i don't know what privacy is does it
turn on an electromagnetic field that
is some lead shielding go over the house
that's what we have we have a system in
which the people who've inherited these
structures have no idea why their
grandparents built them
you